welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who brings
you a breakdown every week made from
blood fat in tears the latest episode of
book of boba fett is now out and in this
video we're going to be breaking down
all the easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed we'll also be talking
fan theories and where the series could
be going in the future to bring you up
to light speed with all the leaks and
rumors now there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then i'll see you darth
later please like the video if you enjoy
it and don't forget to subscribe to make
sure i'll see chewbacca the next one
without the way here thanks for clicking
this now let's get into the book of boba
fett i hope you don't regret that click
now episode 3 saw boba recruiting a
vespa gang into his ranks and he also
made peace with the huts after they put
a bounty on his head it was a wookie
mistake and as an apology they gave him
a rancor before they left the planet at
the drop of a hut turns out that they'd
been played by a bigger power and we
learned that the pikes were now coming
to the planet tatooine in order to start
a war i have my own theories about who's
actually controlling them but we'll talk
about that later on in the video in
flashbacks we saw as feck came across
his camp completely destroyed and he set
out to get revenge on the neuto's riders
which should bring you fully up to speed
now episode 4 begins once more with a
close-up of the bacter tank which
mirrors the opening of the first entry
this of course also reflects how luke
was in one during the events of empire
and they are used for their healing
qualities you might have noticed
throughout the series that burba has
gotten less and less scarred and come
the midpoint we learn that he's finally
healed the twin sons of tatooine also
orbit in the background and the framing
device of the tank of course lets us
know that we are getting a flashback
this episode pretty much recounts how
bubba met fennick and how they formed
their lifelong friendship now we
actually dropped a video on monday
discussing how he thought the flashback
in this episode might happen alongside
episode 5 of the mandalorian which ended
with boba coming across her body looks
like everything's coming at milhouse as
we also thought he'd try to get not
slave one so no matter what happens we
at least got two fan theories right you
can take it to the bank now i'm saying
not slave one as there was a big
controversy around the name change of
the ship last year and they're now just
referring to it as the fire spray which
was the designation that it originally
had when django took it either way it
means that in the last episode that peli
motto was actually on her way to the
hangout where she met mando the
stormtrooper helmets being put on spikes
are also something that mando passed and
i love how his and vet's paths almost
intertwined there is a big hint in the
final scene of the episode that he will
be coming back but we'll talk about that
later on in the breakdown now in the
flashback we watched boba on the back of
the bantha mirroring the scene from last
week however this time the creature
moans and sighs sounding depressed about
losing its family we also passed the
bones of a bantha amongst the dune which
may be from when they were shot during
the train scene in episode 2. the idea
of bones amongst the sand evokes the
imagery of the crate dragon skeleton
that was seen at the start of a new hope
and it shows the death that ferret now
rides out amongst he goes to jabba's
palace and we see an area that hasn't
ever been shown in live action before
which is the hangar he surveys the area
but upon seeing the nektos decides
there's too many gods interestingly fett
says still too many gods showing that
this isn't the first time he's scoped
out the area so i'm guessing that the
neat dose constantly put him off the
nittos were of course behind the camp
slaughter last week and thus he set up a
fire for the night now just in the same
way that tatooine has twin sons we see
that it has triple moons which i believe
hasn't been shown before i'm trying to
think of the night sky and clone wars
ever took focus but to the best of my
knowledge i don't think it has but yeah
we don't know everything but remember
yeah i did get those two fan theories
right so just let me off the hook now
the piece is broken by a flare shooting
in the sky which is what manor used a
blind fenix sniper when he and the
gunslinger flanked her that arrives at
the scene which is where we see the
other side of episode 5 of the
mandalorian at this point we occur to
the titles and get the name of this
entry which is the gathering storm
typically the phrase refers to the
build-up of trouble in which you can
slowly see things slotting into place
and you know there's no avoiding what's
coming the gathering storm was also the
name of a documentary based on winston
churchill in his days during the run-up
to world war ii and it's very much a
phrase used in the build-up to a battle
this not only refers to what happens in
this entry but it's also very much what
happens at the end and there's a lot of
things slotting into place that lets us
know a war is coming now as for fennec
shand though we've spent a lot of time
with her we haven't gone into a
backstory yet i know a lot of you didn't
watch the bad batch so just in case you
didn't the series followed a group of
rogue clones who ended up fleeing from
the empire after order 66. the majority
of the chips in their heads
malfunctioned and thus they didn't feel
like carrying out the kill orders but
this left them in a vulnerable position
as they were left attempting to avoid
the empire they fled kamino and with
them was a young female clone of django
who was called omega though she hasn't
been brought up in the series so far
omega is somewhat boba's sister and much
like him she doesn't have the
accelerated aging that the other clones
do the cameras were split down the
middle over what to do with her and
several bounty hunters were hired to
bring her in on one side was nala say
who wanted omega protected and she hired
fenix shanta into scepter on the planet
pantora the bad match eventually managed
to get her back and later on in the
series when cadbane caught omega shan
was the one who stopped him from going
off to the empire the pair had a battle
on the boro vo cloning facility that
shan ended up winning and both she and
boba have somewhat of a rivalry with
bane having protected omega she ended up
completing her job and we know that she
became a master assassin after the
events of the bad batch fennec has
worked for several crime syndicates and
she's also been a member of the imperial
security bureau after the battle of
jakku the new republic took back control
and they put several bounties on the
heads of imperial officers this included
shand and she fled to tatooine carrying
a bounty of 10 000 credits that takes us
to the events of the mandalorian episode
5 where she was hunted by mando and that
she'd have you pretty much up to speed
if you didn't check out the animated
show now one thing that's a big priority
the characters in the star wars universe
is privacy if the emperor had used a vpn
to hide out in rise of skywalker then
nobody would have known that somehow
palpatine returned that's why i've
teamed up with private internet access
to bring you from the dark side with a
new amazing offer viewers of the channel
can now get a three-year subscription
with four extra free months for only
1.98 a month well paul that's 83 percent
off
i know you punk that's why it's the best
the 100 open source software has had
over 30 million downloads and private
internet access have over 10 years
expertise in protecting you from darth
vader's probe droids browsing your
internet history now you might not know
this but when you're on disney plus you
get different content depending on what
part of the world you're in for example
in the uk i get access to star which has
a whole host of movies from fox as well
as a lot of tv shows however the us
doesn't get this and it's an outrage
it's a bloody outrage and i'm furious
for you little trick though if you use
private internet access you can actually
change what country your browser thinks
you're in and this opens up a whole new
lot of movies and shows for you to check
out
well paul you saved my life i will never
forget how amazing this was
private internet access works with every
streaming service and it's also
compatible with windows mac os android
linux ios and a lot more whilst most of
the vpns support few connections you can
also use one private internet access
subscription to protect up to 10 devices
at the same time the force is strong
with this one and you will click the
link in the description for 83 off a
three-year subscription there's four
three months included in the price and
it works out just a dollar ninety-eight
a month there's also a 30-day money-back
guarantee so why not try it out
risk-free and if you don't enjoy your
newfound online freedom then just return
it for a full refund this is an amazing
deal to start the year so check it out
now in the description below cheers now
fett comes across another enhanced vespa
gang and it shows the style of the kids
is slowly going in this direction
several of them have eye modifications
which mirrors those that appeared last
week and also silo four from the
expanded lore interestingly when peel
went defeat and requested he took out
the gang he looked down upon them for
having modifications shan gave him a
look and we now know that this is
because she had the same ones that the
gang had this also explains why fett
wanted to side with them instead of the
vapor manga and i love learning about
his past now last week we did say that
this could potentially be arden lin
however the character has been revealed
to be called drash i know people still
think that it could be lin going under a
new alias but we'll leave that theory
until we get more info on her backstory
and i thought i'd just correct that here
now one of the people gets an implant at
the top of his spine and i actually got
a lot of imagery when doc ock had
something similar done in spider-man 2.
it's sort of got the aura of a tattoo
parlor and as someone who's had several
late night ones you can walk in without
an appointment if you put up the dough
the modifier initially has a super
battle droid hand but he swaps this out
for a more accurate instrument him
possessing this shows how scrappy that
these modifiers are and they much like
the jawas likely scavenge for whatever
parts they can find which explains why
they look mechanic whereas luke's hand
replacement did look real we get
somewhat of a surgery scene with some
dance music in the background that makes
me unsure whether this is a cyber
hangout or it's 10 downing street hey
you're having that now shout out to
matthew matangi on twitter for pointing
out that this guy is a musician called
thundercat and i think he might have
composed the music for the scene now
they want to leave the machinery on
display but as we know from the
mandalorian fennick did cover it up she
was dying from a gut shot but fett saved
her life and now she's indebted sipping
on a black melon the pair talk about
boba fett and also what his legend means
now shand like the rest of us believe
that burba was dead but he explains the
backstory he calls to try be camped with
the sam people a term that sees them as
people rather than the dehumanizing
tuskens which is what shan refers to
them as they're often called tuscan
raiders but this shows they're different
shan says that vet should ask for the
ship back but with the fall of jabba
they're obviously gonna try and hold on
to anything that they can the pair
travel day and night to get to jabba's
and shan sits atop the ridge looking out
she's pretty angry that she has to pay
off a life debt and shout out simon a
birmingham for pointing out that this
was also brought up in the phantom
menace if a user remember jojo binks two
had one and i like that this tradition
carries on now shan surveys the area
with a miniature probe droid that
carries the eyes of its larger imperial
counterpart just in the same way that
the one sent out by vader spun up and
then floated around this does too and it
flies into the hangar which is where we
catch our first look at the fire spray
sitting in the background maul also had
smaller round probe droids and it sort
of seems like a cross between the two he
counts all the gods there and tech like
this shows how shand was so ahead of the
game when it came to being a mercenary
boba says goodbye to the bantha and i
hope we get the second ever star wars
post credits scene in which we see it
making babies now before the gathering
storm fett lays out his plans of getting
his armor back and taking the throne
he's tired of being a bounty hunter and
wants to rule instead of being given
jobs by idiots sham brings him up
heading agotra and typically in star
wars this is someone who fights for
droid's right we have seen throughout
the saga how initially they weren't
allowed in bars because people hated how
droids were used as soldiers during the
events of the clone wars however things
were changed androids were allowed into
society because of droid gotras who
helped them out now the use of the word
gotra here doesn't mean that but i
thought i'd just bring it up because it
has popped up in star wars before the
usage during this scene actually pulls
from the typical meaning of the word
which typically means a large group of
people that fett wants to now lead now
fed interestingly calls the sam people
tuskins here perhaps showing that he's
tried to find familiarity with shand the
droid returns with its map and this
carries a layout much like what 88 had
last week i did go back and was hoping
that i'd see a little probe droid there
but alas it was just the standard
astromech one fett and shan decide to
sneak in and they go to a sewage tunnel
surrounded by rats similar to what we
saw in jabba's palace during return of
the jedi i love seeing the pair working
together and i know the flashbacks are
getting a lot of criticism online but i
i like them and i'm kind of sad that
this might be the last one now we see a
returning droid evie
who was in return of the jedi this was
the punk that gave r2d2 the job on the
sail barge and he's now working as a
chef in the film the droid was actually
voiced by richard marquande who also
directed that movie he sadly died in
1987 but they managed to recapture the
vocal performance perfectly and it
brings it all together really well now
it was believed that ev99 also appeared
in episode 5 of the mandalorian working
in the most icely cantina but either
that's a different model or my guy has
to work two jobs now in order to pay the
bills there's also the ceo kook droid
which has popped up in the clone wars
and a couple of movies he does a little
spin technique that general grievous
also pulled out with lightsabers but
like with grievous it doesn't really do
all that much an lep droid then comes in
to survey the scene and these two have
appeared in the clone wars they're
typically servants and they also have a
cute little scene where fett chases it
about the kitchen it shuts itself off
rather than facing boba and i thought it
was quite funny but yeah i can imagine
people are raging they're angry at this
now in the hangar they come across the
ship and also see a gunk droid that
seems double the length of what we
typically tend to get they're basically
walking batteries which explains why it
explodes after shan shoots it guards
rush the hangar as fetch starts up
sorry the fire spray and i got a lot of
flashes of attack of the clones when
django fought obi-wan similar to that
scene fett sits in the seat whilst the
action plays out outside and he starts
to ready the ride one of the guards
shouts slimo a curse word on tatooine
and a little skiff is shoved out the way
this was a vehicle that was seen riding
alongside jabba's sailboat and it's a
nice little bit to have hang in the
hangar unfortunately fett finds it
difficult maneuvering the ship but shan
shoots the way to open the gate and thus
they're able to finally fly out the
palace now fett says the ship is a
little rusty but she's in good shape
which is sort of him talking about
himself he clears fenix dead but she
says she'd rather come along for the
ride now we go to the nikdos gang and
fett does what i was hoping he would do
he just pulls up and completely
annihilates them all now i did theorize
that this would be the first port of
call after getting the ship and watching
him just wipe them out did kind of bring
a smile to my face which i'm sure you
can tell now next they go to the sarlacc
pit and we catch the wreckage of jabba's
sailboat there now another thing fett
does here is that he confirms the
timeline we know that the mandalorian
season one happened five to six years
after the events of return of the jedi
and when i did the fan theory one thing
i said was that in order for it to
happen that way that fet would have had
to have been with the sand people for
that amount of time too fett says he
lost his armor all those years ago which
cements that he was with them for a long
time fett of course doesn't remember his
armor getting taken by the jawas so he
still thinks it's here there's a really
creepy atmosphere to it and watching the
image of the teeth surrounding the ship
is really tense as it starts to scan the
area he is quite literally traveling
into the belly of the beast and the idea
of teeth in a mouth closing around them
was of course seen in the empire strikes
back however it was also used in the
iconography of jabba's palace gate
you're just waiting for a jump scare and
this comes in the form of the beak head
that was added in the special editions
and though it was regarded as one of the
worst changes lucas did i think it
actually works really well for once it
seems really menacing as the tentacles
wrap around the ship and it's one of the
tensest moments that we've had in the
season so far fennek ends up dropping a
sonic bomb into it which is also
something that barbara and django used
in attack of the clones these have such
a cool sound effect to them and back in
the day when thx was a thing this was
pretty big
now fair climbs inside the beast to look
for it and he comes out covered in
stomach acid which is what the creature
used to digest its victims shan says he
needs to find a bacter tank and hey
that's that's that thing in the show
that's a that's a great easter egg now
if it offers shan something new loyalty
a home and someone who won't just send
her off on jobs that she could die on
because they have a high price that
basically just wants to go self-employed
and living amongst the tuscans has made
him realize that he needs others with
anger curts of the mandalorian in which
boba took the throne from bib i do think
that this might be the end of the
flashbacks however they might still fill
in him seeing kobanth and also what was
going on during the events of the
mandalorian season 2. however they do
say that he's completely healed so
there's no need to go back to the tank
at this point i feel kind of sad yet
because that was the best pun i had and
now i can't use that anymore now fett
wants an update on the mez major domo
and shan says he's singing like a yazoom
but still no sign of the mayor a yazoom
is actually the creature that was part
of jabba's ban and shan also calls the
bike gang the mods british mud culture
and their vespers were actually the
inspiration for the gang and i
appreciate how they've taken the idea of
mods and changed it to mean people
who've modified themselves good at the
sanctuary where we once more see an rx3
droid that you might know from the
galaxy tours here sits black rasantin
still wallowing in defeat here he looks
over some trans oceans and in case you
don't know in the comics storyline some
actually came to his home planet
kashyyyk in order to enslave his people
he was actually on the run at this point
but he did end up killing them and then
fled off world where he was made a
gladiator which two gets a mention in
this entry when gaza brings up his years
in the pits he ended up being a slave of
the zonti brothers who put metal in his
hands to give him permanent knuckle
dusters however after he was
electrocuted by c-3po i think he's
decided to use the exterior once instead
gaza breaks up the fight and we can once
more catch max rebo sitting on the keys
she talks about the golden days and how
times are more civilized than those when
he was a gladiator she also calls him
santo a nickname that he had in the
comics she promises to wipe his debt but
he rips off the transocean's arms and we
learn in a new hope that wookies have a
reputation for doing this sort of thing
that gives him a job and we get the
scene from the trailers in which he sits
down for dinner with jabba's captains
amongst these are the aqualish
claytonians and trendocions these are
the three quote-unquote families that
were brought up in the last episode and
it's nice that boba's finally having a
face to face with them all after jabba
fell we learned of the power vacuum that
was created and because no one respected
bib's rule they refused to follow him
bear tells them he doesn't want tribute
or their territory he just wants the
pikes out of most esper now as for the
pike syndicate they're actually a lot
less horrifying in live action than they
are in the animated series in the clone
wars and especially the bad batch they
were completely ruthless drug dealers
that were happy to wipe out the batch on
the off chance that they messed with
their supply they've kind of been nerfed
for live action and honest terrifying in
the show or solo a star wars story
however they're definitely not to be
trifled with and will mess you up blood
if you say your favorite band isn't the
spice girls now in case you're not fully
up to speed the home obadiah exists at
the end of the kessel run and they've
been part of the distribution of spice
amongst the galaxy for several decades
spice is basically a hallucinogenic
space drug based off the one of the same
name from june and we actually saw phet
feeling the effects of this during his
visions in episode 2. the synagogue have
been part of several criminal
organizations and they were even
responsible for the death of sifo diaz
who you've probably heard mentioned in
the saga before they were also extremely
loyal to darth maul's shadow collective
which he ended up creating after his
fall from grace he's a guy who's also
dealt with a lot of spice too and if you
enter high ground at the checkout you
get half off hey half off because the
lad got cut in half at the mall the
darth maul hey you get it good good pun
that anyway their proximity to mall and
his leadership of crimson dawn may mean
that they're now working under kira who
could have taken over the organization
at some point i have some theories
beyond this yet but we'll talk about
that more later in the spoiler side of
the video now initially they don't want
to join him but after realizing they're
dining above something that wants to
dine on them they sit and listen to his
proposal that wants a union until the
pikes are out and as fennick mentioned
the nektos gang wouldn't be enough to
take out the tuscans therefore i think
the pikes had a hand in it too and fett
seems to know this he asks that they
remain neutral so that he's not fighting
other families and they agree the
equality has to have ata transit what he
says and this was somewhat seen in the
pond above a bar fight in a new hope for
some reason there i really struggled
saying panda baba bar fight anyway luke
had to have luke had to have how much of
a punk punky was translated and it's
nice that this kinda carries across two
fennec and boba look over the balcony as
the groups head out into the night and
fett decides that they need some muscle
now at this point we end with the theme
of the mandalorian which i'm guessing
means that they're gonna go and hire him
last we saw him he was saying good cry
to grogu so the guy is once more free
agent to me the score being brought in
means he's gonna be coming back and he's
a major character that everyone of
course wants to learn about discovering
what happened to him after he said
goodbye to his boy is something we all
want to know the answer to and i'm hyped
for what could come around the corner
now as for the full theory part of the
video in order to talk about this i have
to talk about some of the rumors and
reports that are currently floating
around about the series if these turn
out to be true then the next part of the
video will be chock-a-block with
spoilers so check out now if you don't
want anything ruined okay so yeah i'm
just waiting just just in case you
haven't left have you gone great good i
tell you what guys that lad he's alright
anyway several newspapers have reported
that han solo will be appearing in the
series and that he will be played by d.h
harrison ford ford allegedly filmed for
several days in london and his role will
somewhat be similar to skywalker's in
the mandalorian now if this is the case
i can see it tying in with kira quite
heavily as the two of course had a
little thing going on kira ended up
leaving hand so that she could pursue
her dreams of being a crime lord and if
she's the big bag controlling the pikes
then potentially both she and han could
come face to face once more the pair
never really got closure from each other
and as of now we're unsure exactly
what's happened to her after her
hologram call with maul however we do
know that he died and thus there is an
opening for her to take over the reigns
of crimson dawn the pikes have of course
worked closely with maul before and
therefore with his fall kira could have
potentially come in and started working
with them too would be absolutely
amazing to see amelia clark return and
if han came face to face with her i
think it would add a whole new level to
the series now this is all based on
guesswork around a rumor that might not
even be true but i think that would be
so great to see and i'll of course be
back next week when we break down the
fifth entry i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know and also huge
shout outs again to private internet
access for sponsoring the video the link
is in the description below if you want
to get 83 off so definitely go check it
out now we are also running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of an mcu boxer of your
choice on the 30th of january all you
have to do to begin with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
moonlight trailer which will be linked
on screen right now we pointed out all
the easter eggs in it and talked about
some of the plot details so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more with out of the way
thank you for saying through the video
i've been poor let's see on the next one
take care peace
[Music]